so welcome to hot breath live everyone
today's guest is one of our most popular
and hot breath history since he did the
show his career has taken off I won't
say it's the hot breath bump but it may
be the hot breath bump welcome to hot
breath live dusty slay everyone all
right it is true you know I was down in
Atlanta doing the Laughing Skull
Festival I did your podcast and then my
career took off that's right you know
there's a lot of things that could you
know could take credit but I mean you
can't deny that it was so long that same
line and it what's great I've you gave
me this shirt when we didn't even really
know each other we did the interview on
the steps of your Airbnb yeah and then
afterwards you gave me all of your
albums and you gave me this shirt that I
now wear on every single road trip I
take when I'm out on the road doing
comedy I wear this shirt every time and
it was it was just like it's a moment in
my career that it him just that always
reminds me hey be a good person like
just be nice we even really know each
other yet but you were like hey that was
fun take everything I have that I
normally sell out on the road here for
you it was just great yeah and then now
all the road trips you're wearing the
shirt
so you're just advertising and it's all
out there but see that's what stuck with
me is that it was all just I think the
positive intention behind it and you not
really expecting anything out of it just
besides helping out and being generous
with another comedian it now sticks with
me that I'd wear this shirt and I'm
almost more likely to wear it because of
that sentiment as opposed to if I did
buy it it almost has more value because
you gave it to me if that makes sense
yeah my grandmother would never throw
away anything anyone gave her and she
had a lot of stuff and how we would be
like why don't you throw this out she
goes I can't Gloria gave that to me what
was it was this with the blanket that
you saw her boobs through was that one
yeah same grandmother but it could be
anything you know she had a card shuffle
oh that was in a package that had never
been opened she wouldn't let me open it
to play with it but she wouldn't throw
it away
because someone gave it to her so I
don't even like people giving me things
cuz I'm like now I'll have to have this
forever its genetic
yeah yeah well this is a we got people
already commenting this is great
Paul well Paul Schneider this is how we
do q and A's here this is hot breath
live you get to ask your favorite
comedians your favorite questions and
Paul he's a Charlotte comic he doesn't
have a question he just said he's a big
fan all right thanks Paul
great hearing from you we're having a
good time we are having a good time
yeah yeah yeah yeah the hand I love it
I'm trapped at home but you know what
I'm loving it honestly this is the time
of my life this is what I've always
wanted to do is just not have a job and
nobody yell at me about it what is your
uh like what do you what are you doing
now because you you had like a national
tour I mean you were booked you're
booked out you know like what what
happened what did you lose and how are
you kind of capitalizing now on this
moment
well my management team an agent you
know it's since you know since doing
your podcast I picked up a management
and agents right it's very good for me
and I they're you know they're trying to
move the dates that they can move you
know so you know it's like I lost the
rest of March and probably all of April
and who knows about May but you know I
mean I'm always planning to get
cancelled you know cuz there's no job
security in anything right so I've been
saying I'm always saving money so that
if things like this go down who knew it
would be a global plague but I could
very well just lose my job so I'm always
playing it you know so I feel okay right
now and I just been building birdhouses
I was just building a birdhouse before I
took this call and I've been painting
building some shelves I'm getting into
the plant world I've been growing grass
I'm getting into landscaping but I got a
lot of birds coming I got some blue jays
I got some Cardinals I got
some some Robbins some doves I mean I
got it going on back there building
birdhouses it's gonna be a new merch
line maybe of dusty slay yeah who knows
I mean I'm you know I'm living my own
joke where I said I feel like I'm
getting a little older the other day I
was sitting in my backyard and I saw
this bird and I was like wonder what
kind of bird that is wish I could see it
up close wonder what he's eating right
now and then I was like oh then I
realize I'm not getting old I'm just
real high right now
well now I'm leaning into the bird thing
I love seeing those birds oh that's a
fun fact about dusty slay there he's
leaning into the birds I got a bird bath
back there I did a little video dusty in
nature video with oh I saw that yeah
yeah yeah oh and it's uh we got people
commenting we're having a good time
people are loving the good time yeah I
mean I this is what you know John Prine
just died and he had country singer he
had a song called sour grapes he said I
don't I wouldn't work cuz I don't need
money well you know it's a longer verse
but basically he's saying he wouldn't
have a job if not for people thinking
that he was lazy so that's where I'm at
who needs a job right it's like we got
to pay rent obviously we got to pay our
bills but dang all this working we're
doing all the time what's going on out
here
well do you have any tips for comics
that are like in this quarantine and
they're like what oh well what do I do
now type deal any words of encouragement
or advice well I would say now is a good
time to create social media content but
not but but you have the free time to do
good stuff right I feel like everybody
in the beginning was just slamming stuff
out because they were like oh I got to
get it out I got to be the first one to
talk about the quarantine I say you can
forget all about the quarantine and just
do the content that you've always wanted
to do right now is your time you got
free time you got nothing to do I mean I
know that I can kill time I mean I'm
watching
Planet of the Apes movies and stuff like
that you know when I should be out
building birdhouses but actually Duke
building the birdhouses helps me think
of other things I get into you know it
reminds me of when I used to have a job
I used to think of so many jokes when I
had a job hmm and now it's harder to
come up with jokes cuz I'm just living
in hotels all the time so I'm finally
like getting to do some stuff I'm going
to Lowe's yelling at people in there for
telling me to social distance from
people I was in at Lowe's two days ago
and I'm wearing a mask I'm wearing
gloves I'm the only person in they're
not the only but pretty much the only
person in there with gloves and a mask
and I'm in line they got these little
X's where they want you to stand on as
you're checking out so that you're far
enough away and I was on my ex I'm the
only person in line including the
cashier with gloves and a mask I'm on my
ex the lady comes the lady in front of
me is not on her ex and she's close to
me but I don't care I'm covered and the
lady comes from behind the cash register
yells at me and tells me to give this
lady her space and I said I'm standing
on the F and acts but I didn't say
effing I was wondering well yeah you
actually said that I let him have it in
there I was like I'm the only person in
here that seems to even care about this
thing and you're yelling at me I'm not
have it I'm not having it and then these
guys when I left out of the store they
were coming in they didn't have the mass
they didn't have gloves and they were
you know they were really trying to
tough they were trying to look at me
like I'm some kind of idiot you know
like they want to they're like trying to
make heavy eye contact with me like
they're making fun of me with their eyes
but I'm not having it I gave them a wave
with my gloved hand
yeah the gloved Wow that's great yeah
I'd love for them to ask me about it why
are you wearing all that well cuz I
don't want to catch coronavirus I'm
trying to breathe around here you know
what I mean well speaking of being in
people's safety zone we have a question
about Bert so you you opened up for Bert
Kreischer oh yeah
body shots world tour which I would love
to hear more about in detail but skip
angel
I believe skip on hell on gel he's out
in Louisiana actually in Lafayette I met
him arrived as Lafayette yes great great
comedy town they got great shows their
show there Lafayette at the oh I don't
know I did a some hookah bar one time
that was a good time but I think I did
Baton Rouge I did the station oh yeah it
was I did a little run through Louisiana
last year it was fun so some Leonard yes
exactly yeah he commented a skip said it
does Burt drink as much as people think
well you know it you know I've worked
with him a few times the first time I
worked with him was in Lexington
Kentucky at comedy off Broadway and I
guess he was sick and he really didn't
drink much at all he would just drink
during the shows and and then he
wouldn't party at all after and then on
the body shot store he parties hard but
during the day he didn't drink he went
for runs and he he wouldn't drink and
then he would wouldn't drink until the
second show of the night but yeah then
it's you know then it's boss of the wall
I mean the guy is after the show I mean
it's let loose and I mean it's fun he
never I never always saw him one time
and all the nights we were together
where he seemed like he got pretty drunk
I mean he handles it well for me a
person that doesn't drink I mean the
biggest problem for me is that Burt
would get super drunk and just want to
hang out all night and I'm up till 4:00
a.m. drinking coffee just trying to stay
awake it'd be a blast if I still drank
but there's nothing for me to do I'm
just hanging out like still very aware
of everything going on
I've been who stayed out till like 4:00
a.m. in New Orleans oh yeah I mean it's
and I'm walking back to the bus with all
of them like very sober and walking by
guys being like I got that coke I got
that coke and I'm like even if I were
look
for coke right now I don't think I want
it from a guy on the street at 4:00 a.m.
in New Orleans yeah I mean I'm not
trying to snort baking soda out here I
bet his fans are crazy too though I
would imagine they go wild they're so
great I mean the best thing about the
tour I mean cuz Birds very nice I like
him a lot but the he would invite we
would do two shows in every city and he
would invite he would tell the club or
tell the people where we were going
after hmm so we would walk into these
bars after the show and it's like we're
like celebrities even me I'm like you
know I mean I say even me only because
I'm not popular like Bert Kreischer is
popular but it was amazing because my
shows were going well so I would walk in
and people were excited to see me and I
loved it I love being on that tour I
mean honestly I just want Bert to let me
go to sleep
[Laughter]
yeah I mean I'm like really yeah I mean
I I like to do my show and then I go
back to my hotel and hang out for a
couple hours I don't mind popping into a
bar for a second but I don't lie I'm not
trying to hang do you have any favorites
well the quarantine is honestly not been
bad for me because I like just hanging
out at home if I had more land I would
never want this to end
but the yeah I mean I don't know I mean
it was pretty much all the same all
throughout I mean the shows were great
it was all theaters the shows were great
and then you know going out especially
the first run that we did was really
because I went on two runs but we went
from I don't know we went up into Canada
we did Toronto I think that's where we
started actually we did two nights in
Toronto then we went to Ottawa then we
drove all the way from Ottawa to
Indianapolis which is great on a bus cuz
you just sleep and then we did
Indianapolis and then st. Louis and that
was a great run because we went out
every night and it was fun it was a
really really a blast and then we did
New Orleans all
in Dallas and we went out in New Orleans
and in Austin both pretty wild times I
think by the time we got to Dallas
everybody was pretty wore down so we
just hung out oh he has a follow-up as
well skip does it's a DJ did you learn
anything good writing slash performing
tips from the tour or from Burt
specifically uh you know the thing that
Burt told me and this was when we were
in Lexington and this was before me and
Burt actually have the same management
now and this was this was before that in
Lexington this was before that and he
told me he was like you know if you're
gonna be and I was featuring for him he
was like if you're gonna be out here
working the road like this and not
moving to New York not moving to LA you
say you got to be writing all the time
he said because what happens to guys on
the road is they get their hour their
hour is great they tell it everywhere
they never write any new jokes and then
by the time it's time for them to start
writing new jokes they've not been
working that muscle that they had built
up to write those jokes so now they're
like a newbie trying to write jokes
again and he's like it's important to
always be writing I think that's the
biggest thing I learned from Burt I mean
I mean what Burt has in my opinion is
not something that can be learned or
taught I mean he just has a real ability
to be this likeable party guy that
people want to hang with they want a
party with they want to hear his stories
I think he's a great storyteller and
it's fun to watch him tell those stories
but yeah I don't know that I don't know
that you could take what Burt has and
teach to somebody mm-hmm you know what I
mean like the guy I mean when when he
would start that he would do and he
would do an hour 15 every night and when
he he would do the the and that's
another thing I mean we did a 90-minute
show I did 15 minutes he did an hour 15
that's what I want to do I get a little
I get a little bored of the same routine
of host feature headline
because I don't want people doing that
much time on my show because I want it
to be my show I'm there to to put on a
thing and if I give 45 minutes of 90
minutes up to someone else
it's barely my show by the time I hit
the stage they're already dropping the
checks and I'm just kind of winding them
down I want to do so what what my plan
is is to get to that place where I'm
doing an hour 15 and my opener does 15
that's what I'd love to do but I mean
when he would start that machine story
we're like an hour and five into the
show and he would say you know he would
start it how he starts it you know I
went to college at Florida State and got
involved with the Russian mafia I mean
the sound the audience made was
unbelievable one time I was behind him
in Dallas like behind a curtain and I
almost could feel the sound when people
started to cheer for that you could like
feel it like a wave hit you mm-hmm and
it's like you know Bert's just amazing
on social media he really works it he's
always working I mean he would do a
video and then we would go back to the
bus and he would be drunk editing
editing a video that he was gonna post
you know Wow it's into it but it shows
that's why he's one of those guys though
that like just stayed consistently
grinding consistently working and being
consistently funny and it paid off in
the long term it's not the road a lot of
especially younger comics want to hear
that oh you mean he just paid his dues
and kept honing his craft and one day it
paid off you know like a few decades
later but he really is an example of
that yeah he was on the road so much and
he you know he told me that he well he
just works right he works like when we
drove from Ottawa to Indianapolis that's
a really long drive and it was a
snowstorm and we were in a bus so it was
even longer than normal we stayed up
really late everybody was drinking
partying and then he got up and called
in to Bob and Tom you know the radio
station there even though both of his
Theater shows and Indianapolis were
already sold out like he still did it
like he's he works he works hard and
that's what you know he worked the road
for a long time he eat and it's like
that's what a lot of people I think just
forget about they forget about the fact
that you have to work it doesn't end I
mean for me when things really started
to pick up I'm working harder than ever
like I got an agent booking for me I got
managers setting things up I got
information coming at me like never
before but I'm working harder than ever
I got more people helping me carry the
load and I still have more to do so
there's another good question
well Carly sherek says birds are
terrifying and Robin Clark said I think
we have the same grandmother so that's a
good time right yeah so John Chappelle
here asks he's an atlanta-based comic
he's newer he's only done a handful of
times but he's super active and eager to
learn which is a great great thing to
have so he says other than being on hot
breath was there a significant event
slash action that helped advance your
career to where it is now hmm
well I mean I think all of them helped
write but the I just think the key to to
it I mean in who knows but it's just
being ready like being ready to perform
whatever thing you get right it's like
they always talked about you could get
something too early and not be ready for
it and then not get another shot at it
it's like you know I did laughing school
three times and the first two times I
got nothing I did the festival two to
three times the first two got nothing
not even really any attention I made
some friends but no industry talked to
me I didn't make any headway even though
my sets were good I was having good sets
but the third time I was doing an
industry showcase and I honestly could
have cared less right I was like I want
to do well so when I say I don't
here I don't mean I don't put in the
effort I still care about making people
laugh but I didn't care about the
industry I was like I'm actually doing
really well now on my own with no
industry I could care less I'm just
gonna go out there and do comedy
everybody in the back was pacing around
the room they were nervous they were
like this is our industry showcase and
I'm like well this is Atlanta I've done
it Lana a bunch I'm very comfortable
here so I went out I had a great set I
could have very easily been like I don't
care I'm gonna try some new stuff
tonight but I'm like no I don't care but
I'm still gonna go out and do my best
jokes mm-hmm and then I and so that got
me basically in a roundabout way got me
that jfl Just for Laughs comedy festival
and the same thing there now I cared
about that one but I also was ready I
went in with a plan I came out did my
set I had a great set and then two weeks
later I did The Tonight Show and then
it's just like repeat all those steps
again you're like okay now I've got I
finally got the thing I've been wanting
to get I got a nail it I can't mess
around I can't take chances I got to be
like this is gonna be my these are the
jokes I'm doing I'm going out with my
best I'm honing it I listen to Michael
Cox who's the Booker for The Tonight
Show he wanted me to you know work with
me on my set to help make the perfect
set for late night and I'd listen to him
mm-hmm
I took his advice I listen I like to
take advice from people that are clearly
doing things that I want to be doing I
don't like to take advice from people
whose careers aren't going that well
boom like I've had Booker's that book
small time rooms and they want to tell
me how to do certain things and I'm like
I appreciate it I don't you know just
because you own a small club doesn't
mean I dismiss you but I like to take
advice from people that I can really see
you're doing stuff so like you know and
then so then I nailed the Tonight Show
and you know it's like who knows
how it's gonna go a different night a
different audience maybe it doesn't go
that way
but it went the way it went because I
was prepared I was ready to roll but
what was the preparation for The Tonight
Show in terms of maybe how many times
you ran that set how did you rehearse
that set but then also the Booker
Michael Cox What did he say to you to
help formulate it into like a late-night
set well I think that he I mean I I
chose the jokes I wanted to do and I
recorded it and I sent it to him and he
just helped me he goes well basically
like if you watch that set at the end of
the thing I say you know I'm talking
about the DVDs three four five and then
I say you know this is your deal this is
just three four five two times if you
want I'll buy these three and then I'll
take off this hat and then the audience
cheers and I go thank you have a good
night but that's not how that joke ends
I mean when I do it in a club I say then
I take off this hat and I'll buy these
other three and then I say and that
worked you know and then that it gets a
laugh and then I say she didn't know how
that second guy got there but she sold
him some DVDs right so all of those
lines get get laughs those are to me
that's where the joke is is those next
two line when I say and it worked she
didn't know how that second guy got
there but she bought but Michael Cox
said he goes listen he's like I know The
Tonight Show audience and when you take
off that hat they're gonna laugh and
cheer and I think that's where you
should end it and I was like but that's
not the joke I was like that's not where
I get a laugh at shows and he goes
listen you can do whatever you want to
do you can end it however you want to
end it but when you take off that hat
they're gonna laugh and cheer and I
think that you're out and so he left it
up to me said do whatever you want to do
but when I got to the end and I took off
that hat and they laughed and cheered I
was like wow he was spot-on
mmm-hmm and with with repping out that
set and even like backstage are you
are you do you have a set list you're
going over were you reppin out this set
like how many times you think you ran
this set there's no way to know
I mean it's five minutes and I probably
did it you know I mean no joke probably
ten times at least in my hotel room
god I just because it's like in five and
some most of the time when I'm doing an
hour
I don't even practice my set at all I
know my jokes well enough at least prior
to the shutdown
I knew my jokes well enough to where I
can weave in and out of jokes I can add
in my new jokes anytime I want and you
know I can weave in and out sorry this
someone keeps calling me I had set up a
Facebook call a couple of days ago I
missed it and now they're relentlessly
calling me perfect yeah
but the but I said it so many times in
my hotel room because there's no room
for a mess-up if I'm doing an hour I can
stumble on a joke I mean I've been known
to mess up a joke so bad and I go you
know what I'll come back to it later and
I'll do another ten minutes of jokes and
then I'll do that joke again you know
I'd do jokes out of order sometimes and
then I'll mess up a call back and I'll
tell the audience this is how this joke
would normally go and that's usually
pretty fun but you get five minutes
there's no room for mess-ups at all
mm-hmm-hmm you just gotta gotta get it
all right so I'm like all I want is to
have in my head and then I also had
trimmed up some jokes so the goodwill
joke I had been doing a different way
for a long time so the muscle memory of
that joke kept taking me back to the old
way that I said it so I needed to get
that must I needed to be focused and in
the moment the entire time there was no
room for me to trail off in my mind and
let muscle memory take over I have to be
present in the moment geez well this but
I was so nervous I would go to the
bathroom you know and I would just be
saying some of the jokes aloud in my
head that's why I was like there's
notice it's like everybody in the world
is not watching but everybody in my
world is watching the stakes are so high
in terms of that that's why I had to ask
about how you prepared cuz it's I'm not
prepared for showcases where I'm like
going through it in my head but then I
can't imagine to be filming late-night
and just like just the amount of
preparation and their margin for error
it's like yeah it's razor thin yeah this
this pies I mean the next question but
did you have some cap that oh oh oh
you're right though yeah I wanna I want
to make sure your fans get a they get
their dusty time the hot breath averse
here is very active for Dusty slay I
love it
so the next question from Robin Clark
what's alright it's a two-parter okay
what's the best advice you ever got in
the biz who did you get it from and then
what is your best piece of advice well I
don't really know that there's any way
to say what the best advice that I got
was I mean for me I'm always paying
attention to you know people that are
smarter than me and are wiser than me
and it been around for a while you know
I mean I used to sell pesticides and I
worked for this guy named Stu barber and
he was you know almost 70 years old and
he used to play football for the Buffalo
Bills and he gave me lots of great life
advice that I still use to this day that
even I can take and apply to comedy in a
lot of ways but I mean just as it
pertains to comedy you know I mean when
I first started working the road I got
well I'll say even this I wanted to move
to New York New York was what I wanted
to do I had this whole plan in my head I
went to New York I lived for one month I
didn't fail
and come home I rented an apartment for
one month that's all I had and I went I
did open mics everyday for that entire
time and just and that's what I wanted
to do and I got some advice from my
first manager that I had and they you
know and also from another comic I knew
and he said he lived in Nashville and he
liked Nashville because he got to work
the road because he was so centrally
located to so many places and he got to
become a comic before moving to New York
like so when you when you're doing
comedy working the road as opposed to
living in New York and LA you can become
a full-time comic pretty easy if your
expenses are low and if you're getting
booked so for me it was like alright
let's figure out how to get booked let's
move to Nashville and let's start
working the road and and and then I I
got an offer to do a gig way out in
Clayton North Carolina which is about 8
hours 9 hours from Nashville and it was
for 270 dollars for the weekend so I
would drive this 8 9 hours do two shows
and then drive home for 270 dollars
mm-hmm
and I was like I told the guy who was
you know the manager who I had that was
talking to me at the time I told him
that I was like I don't want to do that
I can't do that and he was like you know
basically he was like you do whatever
you want but he's like I'll tell you you
got to do it I mean he's like if you
want to be a comic you got to do it he
said everybody's done that everybody's
done that long road gig for no money and
he said this this Booker has a lot of
gigs and if you say no to this they're
gonna move you to the bottom of the list
but if you say yes I mean there's no
guarantee you'll stay at the top but
you're not moved down to the bottom so
for me that was good advice at the time
I mean it all depends on for me it's
like the advice depends on where you're
at at the time but I know so many people
I'll go you know they're like oh you
know I want to do that what's that pay
you know and it's like I think if if
what's it pay is on your mind in the
beginning then you're not gonna make it
because
it pays good yep I mean until you reach
a point I mean I'm not saying that I'm I
don't get paid well for gigs now I mean
I'm not rich but III make I do better
now headlining but for a long time I
mean for a long time I did comedy for
free and then I started doing it for
very little money I mean I lived in an
apartment for $250 a month I lived in an
attic an addict room and my car was
already paid for so and I also put three
hundred and seventeen thousand miles on
that car yeah that's part of the
sacrifice I used to live in a studio
apartment in the basement of a building
in the hood of Atlanta like there was a
rap song about the street I was living
on like I mean that's just part of if
you're what sacrifices are you willing
to make for this crazy game of comedy
you know right I mean it's just like you
know it's like for some reason people
think that comedy is a way to escape
work they're like I don't really want to
work I want to do comedy like I made the
joke to somebody today they asked me how
I was doing during the quarantine and I
was like I was like honestly this is the
time of my life I said you know I I do
comedy because it's easier than working
and this is easier than that but now
it's it's easier than working in a lot
of ways I'm not doing manual labor but I
used to drive an unbelievable amount I
mean even before I didn't even realize
how tired I was until this quarantine
happened that's why I'm not Restless
because I've been on the go so much for
so long that I'm like I still feel like
this is just a break for me then this is
just some rest yeah this like go ahead
it almost feels privately like God said
all right I'm quarantined in the country
because dusty needs a break you know
what I mean but you have been I mean on
the road solid every week man it's been
cool and I think that's why so many
comics especially when you have a fan
base but that's why comics I think I
appreciate you so much is because one
they've seen you
develop and they've seen you just grow
doing at your own way like you said out
of Nashville based out of Nashville
you've had all this success and it's
you've just kind of done it not the like
the easy way but you've done it the way
that's gonna have the long-term you know
they say the the long road is longer but
it takes you farther and you're an
example for comics to just stick the
course just stay consistent at what
you're doing and it'll start to
incrementally build over time yeah I
mean I don't want to be famous I want to
have a fan base large enough to where
people will come see me do comedy I just
get to make them laugh
that's all I want I don't I mean I don't
want to be in movies I don't want to you
know I just want I'd love I mean life
can be very simple and I love it that
way I like to keep it simple I mean it
can get wild out there if you try to you
try to stay running this race all the
time I'm like oh no I'm not I'm not
trying to argue with people about
politics on social media I'm not trying
to I'm just trying to live my life I
want to get I'm growing some plants and
birds right now but I'm gonna get into
some vegetables and some fruits I mean I
moved along and yeah I mean I love it I
want to go out make people laugh come
home do a little farming this is all
about it
this also doc Kennedy just said he's in
Nashville doc Kennedy yes and he asked
because this this also shows just where
you are and your mindset around calming
your appreciation for it is he says ask
dusty about doing a show on a motel
rooftop the week after your Tonight Show
debut oh well doc Kennedy had put
together a corporate gig and wench I
don't know how much doc ran through the
I don't know you know honestly I didn't
know I don't because I've done shows
like this on my own plenty of times and
the more you do them the more you
learned what to ask and then you get to
a place where you have a manager that
does all that for you but you know I
don't know that doc knew what to ask
right so we're doing
comedy on a roof he has a guy opening
dock opens yet we have another guy and I
I'd liked him and his name is not coming
to me right now
Castro was his last name and now I can't
Kyle Kyle Castro okay and Kyle I don't
think has was very experienced with
comedy either right so we're on this
rooftop and first off we're in Nashville
and I'm wearing my hat and this lady and
the elevator goes as the doors closing
she's like we don't allow ball caps in
here and I was like well in my head I'm
my well this is a trucker hat but okay
and as I will say I did say that I said
we'll see so I get to the top I mean I
just don't like that we're in Nashville
stop trying to be all fancy
you know what I mean let me wear a hat
in here and learn your hats this is not
a ball cap I'm not playing pickup
baseball after this and so we get to the
top and then it's it's I don't remember
what the company was maybe some kind of
I think it was for Domino's corporate or
something I don't know I had a different
thing in my mind but this guy running
the show was doing surprise comedy for
his staff
oh my so we're on a rooftop there's no
stage there's a very bad sound system
and it's surprise surprise guys I got a
little comedy for you stop what you're
doing stop having a good time stop
talking with your friends and co-workers
sit down be quiet listen to these guys
and then while while Doc's onstage I try
to go I don't know what I'm even trying
to do but I step into the stairwell for
a second and then I get locked out so I
have to go down I have to go down I'm
banging on the door finally some maid
lets me in and then I have to figure out
how to get back up to the top of the
stairs and then I finally work my way
back in there and it was just the whole
show was a fail I mean doc brought it up
I'll just tell you doc bombed Kyle bomb
and then and then so we needed to know
that's what we needed to know I don't I
don't want to say that I bombed I but I
only connected with very few people okay
III don't know that any of us bombed but
we only connected with very few people
don't retract now if they bomb they
bombed you know hey Bob
they did Bob that's the week after
comedy always has a way to keep you
humble the week after The Tonight Show
you're on the roof doing a surprise
comedy show it's just she's yeah always
keeps you humble like that well even
worse than that I mean the Jimmy Kimmel
was pre tanked so I did Jimmy Kimmel was
my very first late night so I pre taped
it so I went I flew to LA I filmed Jimmy
Kimmel and then I flew back to North
Carolina to Raleigh North Carolina and I
did a show that I had put together prior
to learning that I would be doing Jimmy
Kimmel I did this show so Jimmy Kimmel
had not aired yet but I knew that I had
just done it and I'm doing a show in
Raleigh North Carolina for just the
comics and one person who had been
listening to me on Sirius XM so this
girl was a fan she had heard me on
Sirius XM and decided hey he's pretty
close to me I'm gonna go see a show and
she shows up to an audience of just the
comics and her fan so it's a yeah I'm
humbled all the time by comedy and
that's fine but you know what I'm also
lately I just did a corporate gig on a
rooftop in Arizona about two months ago
and I thought I I was going to get to
the party a little early I thought I'll
try to get some food I'll sit in the
green room I take the elevator all the
way to the top the elevator opens I go
oh no this is on a roof and I walk over
I talked to the DJ I see the stage I go
is that where I'm doing comedy in a bit
he said yeah I think so and I just said
oh no this is gonna be terrible and I
got in the elevator went back to my room
and sat there for another 15 20 minutes
because I'm like I'm not dealing with it
until it's time to deal with it yeah and
then I went back up and I got on stage
and I just prepared myself for the
weirdest worst show and then it was
fantastic the audience got into it we
had a great time I even hung out for a
little while and helped them do their
award show it was such a great time
corporate gigs are interesting like that
sometimes they're tear I mean they all
they almost always pay well but there's
usually a price to pay within that that
high payday but some of them will
pleasantly surprise you every corporate
gig I've done since I've had my
management and agent I it has been great
every corporate gig has been great and
every college that I've done has been
great too yeah I'd like to tell colleges
I come out I go hey normally I do comedy
for a lot of old people so if you don't
like these jokes just remember your
parents will love them and then I did my
five o'clock somewhere joke and it went
pretty well but then I said your dad's
would love that joke and Doc Doug said
you uh you set off an alarm that ran
through Kyle's set but that was probably
the most noise that was made during Kyle
set and no I'm just kidding I like Kyle
I'm not trying to trash him hey
everybody bombs but it's it's the
funniest to me when comics bomb - I
always laughed the hardest it's just
something we all go through I did set on
off alarm I forgot that I don't even
remember how I did that but yeah that
place was a mess it was such a nice
hotel but it was a maze well we have
approached it's 1:45 so you have if you
have more questions I could do I mean I
could do 10 more minutes and then I have
a call at 1 Oak a yeah yeah we have a
few here so we'll just try to
just kind of chip him out you know cuz
okay let's uh talk no it's a Sean Patton
on here and he ended up going like two
hours like every answer was like a ten
minute answer so oh yeah cuz I love
comics just like helping comics you know
and that's what this whole show is about
so it's yes Sean Patton is great I
really like them
very good so Paul Schneider asked he
says I love loved all Dusty's podcast
episodes of advice to new comics are
there any new tips that you've come up
with or anything that you've rethought
since putting those out you know I don't
think so I mean it's like it's hard to
admit it's like new tips it's like I put
everything in in that and and I don't
think that I would change anything
because I really spend a lot of time
writing those and just since I did the
process that way I mean it just was me
rethinking everything that I did and I
just think it's you know it's just
important to work hard and not ever
think that it's gonna get easier
it should be fun to you so working
harder shouldn't be that big of a deal
but you know I just think it's important
to know what you want to do you know do
you want to be a comment do you want to
be an actor are you using comedy as a
platform for something else because if
you are then you probably should move to
a bigger city you know a city where that
kind of stuff is happening but if you
just want to be a comic just move
somewhere that you're close to an
airport or centrally located to driving
you know I mean I just think that's the
best and also take advantage of all
kinds of membership programs like if you
start plonk lying get a credit card for
four anime on airline and use that same
airline all the time you build up miles
you build up status and I mean by the
time I mean I was flying for two years
and I'm almost first class on so many
flights now because I'm just I have the
top status with this airline and so it's
like I'm always getting upgraded and I'm
always getting perks and things like
that just because I get to carry
multiple bags for free now
and I know that everybody goes Oh
Southwest all bags are free but
Southwest is weird to me I don't like it
I like I like to know where I'm sitting
I don't like a spur-of-the-moment seat
choice that's good yeah that's good
advice
and you actually inspired me with your
the series you did on your podcast about
tips for comics it inspired me I booked
a two week long tour and then ended up I
did a road trip tip series on my podcast
and I accredited you on your podcast for
inspiring the idea but I did like a
five-week road trip tips series so it's
uh it's very valuable and comics clearly
you know it resonated with Paul and
several others yeah I mean it's like I
don't I mean I just did that you know
one I mean I I never I never try to
pretend that I'm doing anything other
than what I'm doing like I don't I'm not
gonna sit here and go I just deep in my
heart I just cared about everyone and
wanted to do I wanted to give back no I
want to do a podcast and I need content
but I also do care about helping people
right right because I need contact
doesn't mean that I don't care but I'm
not I I hate hate hate when people just
try to act like they're out there I'm
just out here fighting for everyone I'm
just trying to it's like take it easy
we're all a little self-serving you know
what I mean but I want people to I think
that you learn best through experience
but it could also be nice to hear from
someone else from a real take I don't
try to dramatis eyes anything I don't
try to make it or I don't know if
dramatic dramatize I'm not trying to
make anything seem like anything other
than what it is it's work you have to do
it you're not going to get paid well
unless you can figure out how to go
viral but honestly other than the money
I wouldn't want to go viral without
having the material to back it up
oh for sure oh my god you know you'll
get booked and you'll make a bunch of
money but how long can you make that
last I like to think that the the kind
of comedy that I'm building I can do for
yes because I'm not I'm not had some I
don't have some you know um out of
nowhere spike I mean it's been a build
to get to things and also be prepared
for some disappointment I would say I
mean I did Jimmy Kimmel and I don't
think that was my my hottest set I mean
I love the jokes but the set itself
wasn't the hottest set but I didn't
really get much of anything off of that
not
I mean clubs that used to feature me
didn't move me up to headline and I
couldn't even get into any new clubs but
it was a build because now I had done
that and whether that me doing that had
any decision on The Tonight Show whether
they were like oh he's already done a
late night so let's use him whether they
had any thought in that at all I don't
know but it prepared me because I had
prepared for this late night the first
one a certain way and I prepared the
wrong way in my opinion this was advice
that was given to me but I it was wrong
and I don't think they were maliciously
gave me bad advice but it was the wrong
advice so I knew now how to prepare for
a late night and then that's what I did
you know which is which is when I when I
prepared the Tonight Show I opened with
that 5-minute set every show from the
time I was told I was going to do the
Tonight Show until I actually did it
that was my first five minutes sometimes
to my own detriment
like I would come out I would do that
five it would crush people would be
falling out of their chairs and then I
couldn't follow it I couldn't follow my
own so I'd do I'd do five minutes of
killer material and then 40 minutes of
people being like okay buddy yeah yeah
but but when I was ready now for the
Jimmy Kimmel I was told the way to
prepare
they said the audience will be really
hot so what you want to do and this was
not Jimmy Kimmel's people this was
someone else in my life okay and they
said the audience will be hot so when
you practice the set they said do do
about 10 or 15 minutes and then take you
know take a
little pause and then do your five
minutes so that way the audience is hot
while you're practicing it so when I
went out to the Jimmy Kimmel audience
they were not hot at all they the way
Jimmy Kimmel does it was like they're in
one room for the famous people they're
in one room for the music and they're in
one room for the comics that was the old
way it's different now
but so the audience was basically cold
and I came out and opened with material
I had never opened with oh my gosh
alright so it that Wow
so if you watch that set you can notice
that as the set goes along it's starting
to get better and better and better and
that it ends with a big laugh but in the
beginning it was not good but when I do
that said if I did that exact five
minutes in middle way through a set on
almost any stage in the country it's
gonna crush from the first joke to the
last joke it's gonna be bang and I know
that because I that's what I was doing
that's why I chose those jokes all right
let's uh rapid-fire here we're putting a
45 second timer on these these last few
here question 1 do you have any specific
writing exercises you like to do no I
just like to write down every funny idea
that I have and put it in a notebook and
don't throw that notebook away I don't
really write as much as I should but I'd
like to write down ideas and then bring
those to the stage and I just try to
flesh them out on stage okay more on
stage alright Jody Carter asked does
dusty miss Charleston and Jocasta
I miss Charleston you know what I missed
your pasta a little bit because I missed
the Hank
I loved all those people that we used to
hang with hey Jody by the way and I
loved hanging in at Jo pasta but I do
miss Charleston but and there are other
rooms that I miss more than Jo pasta I
miss threw in my open mic at big gun
burger I miss theater 99 I'm
the ten roof open mic Joe pastas pretty
far down on the list but I love stayin
Shelby I love Stan Shelby and I I always
liked doing that that open mic alright
Robin Clark what was the hardest bomb
and what's your advice for surviving a
bomb well I still think that my hardest
bomb was the bomb that I shared on hot
breath podcast the time before opening
for Ares that's still the hardest and so
but my advice is to just get back like
alright let's say this if I'm doing a
weekend somewhere and on Thursday night
my set doesn't go all that well on
Friday I've changed up the order I've
shifted stuff around if it still doesn't
go that well on Friday the second show
I'm shifting more I'm gonna keep
shifting my order around until I find
the I had a weekend where my bet I did
Thursday to Friday to Saturday one
Sunday my best show was Sunday and
that's because I never stopped changing
it until I got it how I wanted it God
now that didn't mean Saturday Friday or
Thursday was bad but they wouldn't where
they weren't where I wanted them to be
so I kept shifting kept fighting yeah
till I got it all right yeah so Robin
don't give up just yeah I mean a bomb it
it sucks
I mean it doesn't matter where you're at
it sucks to bomb you just got to keep
trying got to keep plugging away and it
might not just be the material it might
be how you're telling the joke think
about word economy how can I say this
with less words yep hey Robin nice
question Robin Jon Chappelle's saying
awesome thanks Andy gunan loving very
informative he appreciates the honesty
and experience
Carter slay hashtag truth bombs
Carter Bryant and the final one this
will be a good one to land this plane
with we're gonna make it a two-parter
here because Wayne flake asked how did
you transition from open mic
to doing shows and then Tyler Walsh is
also asking when your opinion on when
someone's ready for a website so I think
that progression can kind of go hand in
hand so how do you go from open mic to
getting on book shows to then when do
you need a website 45 seconds go I would
say just get the website anytime I can't
hurt before I was when I was still open
miking and didn't have any shows I had a
website with my calendar on it and I put
every open mic that I was doing I used
to when I lived in Charleston sometimes
I would do two shows a month and then
one weekly open mic and I so you would
look at my calendar and it was like it
was like big gun burger big gun burger
big gun burger because that's all I was
doing but at least if someone wanted to
look me up they could go to the calendar
and go Oh Dusty's doing a show here on
that night so they could come and see me
that's why I say get the calendar get
the website as fast as you can they're
not expensive you know just get it as
quick as you can and then I would say
get Wix because it's pretty easy wicks
or Squarespace very easy to do
time-consuming but easy and then it was
it how did I go from open micro to doing
shows yeah and then maybe how many were
out in a week well I mean I lived in
Charleston there was very few open mikes
so and there was no comedy club so I was
doing comedy from 2008 until 2013 before
I ever did a club I was just doing bar
shows theatres open mics and theater 99
was an improv theatre and it was our
closest to a club great place but not a
comedy club closest to a club we had and
I did the Charlotte actually I did a
Laughing Skull I did I booked myself an
open-mic trip I looked on comedy club
websites I found out when their open
mics were and I booked myself a road
trip of just open mics and then I worked
a few bar shows in between to fill some
space and hopefully make a little money
but I did the laughing skull open mic
which I had been turned down for the
Laughing Skull Comedy Festival and then
I went and did the open mic made people
laugh
and then the next time I submitted I got
accepted so I did the laughing skull
open mic and then I did a show I got
booked on a show
somehow in it's a knees did a
one-nighter that went really well and
then I did Charlotte comedies own Fight
Night is what they called it and it was
three minutes it's three minutes and I
got third place third place was enough
to advance me to the final round so I
drove back to Charlotte a couple of
weeks later to do three minutes for no
money right something people would say
was stupid they would go why would you
drive all the way to Charlotte North
Carolina keep in mind I didn't even have
a car at the time I was had no license
or I had a license I didn't have a car
I'd sold my sold my car so I was biking
so I rented a car to drive to Charlotte
and do this and then I did and I won so
through winning I got booked to do a
weekend of featuring at the comedy zone
and so my first weekend featuring was
for Josh blue at the Charlotte Comedy
Zone in 2014 so cool yeah and that's
what me accent said yesterday is she she
rose through the ranks doing open mics
at comedy clubs that book comics and
then they saw you be funny and then you
get booked from there yeah so be funny
is the key to getting booked more pretty
much I yeah I always say be nice and be
funny people love to be around nice
people that doesn't mean you have to be
a pushover but be nice be funny everyone
wants to have you at the comedy club
well you are so nice for going in
overtime here
dusty thank you so much for sharing this
Joe and dusty you're the best
everybody goes support dusty dusty
slate.com the podcast let them know
anything everything you say yeah we're
having a good time and I'm on tick-tock
now my tick-tock is at Custis a tick
knock it's so stupid but tick tock is
now my most popular social media I have
the most followers on tick-tock that I
have any other social medias making bird
houses on tick-tock everyone go check
out Dusty's Flay thanks thanks hot
brethren you're the best
have a good day buddy right thanks guys
thanks Joel no problem